all right welcome to a super edition of
a beginner breakdown on Super Tuesday
all right hope y'all went to the polls
and voted for the right candidate
everybody knows who that is obviously
all right so so Friday I was uh I was
not directing but it was at the Friday
action quad and so so Mario or good
friend from the Blitz bounty was playing
a gentleman and and when he came back
from a miraculous down a Brook and
you'll see the position that will go
over that game just a minute he ends up
drawing the game and as a pawn so like I
smashed in the boar and he's like oh
it's really man making a big scene in
the tournament home and so before I
brought two I had to talk to him and say
hey hey hey you know you can't be doing
that
you got to get forfeit and try to calm
down it's like oh I just can't wait to
get it back out there I just can't wait
to get out there play okay and so in
round two we had the black pieces so if
you were playing with the black pieces
and you really really want to just go
out and destroy your opponent what
opening do you think you would play
would you play an opening where you lose
a pawn and put your knight on the side
well that's what this gentleman did and
let's see how it works out okay so so
white plays e4 and e5 Knight f3 knight
c6 Bishop c4 and so so the the agitated
one plays Knight up six he's like yeah
alright so so of course like the kids
pounds Knight g5 and it's like oh no
it's a trick it's a trick yeah you're
not gonna play the fried liver on me
because I know the to make stuff it's
alright so here we go let's see how good
you know it
okay so pawn up so just take the pawn
everybody and now Knight attacks the
bishop hmm let's move it let's move it
to the most aggressive spot we can go
check ok so right now is black you've
you've dropped the pawn and your Knights
looking like a fool right
alright so it's okay so he blocks the
check and so take
take so now now you've isolated your
puns okay but the good good idea really
get the guy right okay so he's like okay
I'm not gonna let you take my bishop
okay and so that might not be the best
move I obviously recommend Bishop to d3
in that position but fine fine so he's
like okay I'm gonna protect my pawn
again and then he's like Bishop there
and he's like who is this kid he's
moving this bishop so much so he's like
I'll attack your knight big mistake okay
all right so what move should you play
as white here yes play a really good one
like a really good move yeah you in the
class let's go so is there anything okay
okay so so unfortunate if you play
Bishop takes f7 check the King would
move and now you have two men the bishop
in the night under attack right okay so
instead of having two men under attack
let's attack two men okay ourselves
right a knight fork as we learned about
it with Lulu right the knight fork as I
go I would never happen to me all right
all right so now the Queen and the rook
are both under attack and now true story
he tries to take all right the agitated
one okay so so if you were in beginner
breakdown and listening to all my
lectures what move would you force the
player playing black to make in this
position
anybody King e7 you touched it I don't
care if your intention wasn't go to f7
your intention was to move the King so
you got to move it and then we eat your
queen okay but but the guy played a
dubious move anyways like oh oh never
mind never mind and so so he plays
Knight takes bishop so we take we take
Retreat or night to safety and it's over
okay so so you know this this opening
isn't the best as we see and now I mean
look look at you and now now true story
but now now it's like so so there's
other instructors and as I got really
special kids so I can teach them I can
teach them so this is how how a game
went in the kids class against a very
special kid okay very special very good
very good player playing black here
right because you know she's got you
know experts as our coach so it's like
we can teach and and this is going to be
great so so just as we've seen here but
now white instead of following all the
book moves okay pulls this one out Queen
to f3 okay so so whatever they played
this you get castle and that up I forgot
my forgot about my rook okay so it's a
hideous opening and I don't know why you
guys keep playing it and teaching it to
kids alright so so let's see the big
Mario come back okay he's playing the
black pieces let's see you how I that
kid got so agitated yes we pull it yeah
we gotta pull it down i right alright so
here here's the game so mario is playing
black against the kid around 100 what do
you think mario is gonna play here one
of the three moves that are legit here
right the classic age six Bishop c5 or
Bishop to e7 barrio obviously picks the
best one Bishop to c5 and the most
aggressive all right
so takes takes if I was Mario I would
give the kid a big check this is a big
rematch from two weeks ago we went over
the game Mario against this kid in the
live at the Metro class championship so
if you want to check that out after the
kid laughs at Mario's moves in the
previous game Mario gets his revenge and
wins the 36 bucks
so this was the revenge game for the kid
playing wait okay so castles Mario's
average gonna play h6 and not let the
bishop get down and pin all right so a
three so that looks like a like a funny
move but as we'll see it has its place
in the game when he when he attacks the
bishop he can just retreat it remember
we went over that the 4-way Bishop you
know Mario's gonna forget about it and
bad things could happen
so the pawn attacks the night so
unfortunately we can't take the D pawn
or Elser night with Hank so we have to
take it takes tonight retreats and b5
here
so unfortunately Mario you know you
could try Knight to be four here but
that when he moves this Bishop
right the night might not have any good
places to go see attacked attacked
attacked as you seek so so Mario has to
go all the way back home and yeah he
really doesn't want to so night attacks
the bishop so [ __ ] tip retreats fish up
the e6 how can you send that Bishop
right back home if you're playing white
just the one downside about that is
though it does activate this bishop now
but you know he decides to play it and I
don't blame them now you know lots of
Mario's pieces are just hanging out on
the back row here so Brook attacks the
pawn it's protected by the knight but
you know get some more protectors on it
alright so Queen out attacks the bishop
and you know if the bishop moves
see you later Knight so he's got to be
pretty careful how he protects this he's
got to protect the bishop or he could
try a trick so discuss somebody's like
threatening to do a trick doesn't
necessarily mean you have to fall for it
right a pass would be a better better
alternative than this then this move so
he takes the bishop big mistake right
huge mistake so when Knight takes the
bishop one our Queens under attack our
rooks under attack or so was our Bishop
so we have to take it and then bye-bye
rook not good Mario not good so so as
now
it's under attack so he moves out his
bishop and discovered protection all
right bye-bye pawn so it's all falling
apart from Mario so yeah you want to
take if you have this this situation you
want to take with the rook right you
don't want to pin you know you don't
want to pin your bishop
so just take rook takes Bishop takes and
it's not looking very good for Mario
right one two three pieces one two three
four so Mario's down a rook and look at
this guy three away from becoming a
queen Martha's got to act quick or else
he's gonna be in big trouble so he
attacks the Queen you know when you're
up try to trade material Mario knows he
doesn't one two so so he retreats the
Queen and now Nathan just starts pushing
the pawn excellent idea so Queen moves
attacks the bishop so let's move the
bishop okay so now Queen blocks the the
square so now I can't not push the pawn
anymore so you just take some more stuff
of Mario's Bishop moves so Knight
attacks the bishop this is not going
very good for Mario at all
so just consolidate it gives them a big
check King moves and now he wants to
trade obviously Mario can't trade so he
moves big mistake big mistake
why was that such a big mistake because
he put his pawn where there was two
attackers and only one defender so what
would have been a much much better move
for the player playing white in this
position there's two acceptable answers
here
well there's Polly anything's better
right but where are some good ideas in
this position yes Kevin
a Queen's on the upright right that I
mean that's definitely the best move
right and then and then yeah where is he
gonna go well you better write right
right yeah cuz if you move anywhere
right the best move piling in this
position for black is just try to
protect the pawn like that so yeah yeah
Queeny some excellent idea another idea
which isn't nearly as good is get the
work behind the pulling right but yeah
but Queenie sevens just forces because
if you move the Queen way for away by
night yes all right so he plays d7 which
is a big mistake right he just gets too
antsy so so Knight takes the pond so
it's a good job Mario all right so now
rook attacks the night he moves it
attacks the pawn and so he pushes the
pawn so Knight up all right so f3 who
thinks f3 is a good move in this
position anybody so now you're you're
you know you can get checked now very
easy on this long diagonal it's a bad
idea but you know he's probably really
upset that he dropped that pawn so he's
not gonna make the best moves
all right so Knight check Knight attacks
the rook rook attacks the Queen
obviously we do not want to take the
pawn everybody see this now what do you
want me to do move this over okay
so obviously we don't want to take the
pawn
I hope everybody's yelling at home the
school discovered attack rook takes
check game over okay so it's all Mario's
like yeah you're not gonna fool me that
easy so he's gotta give him a check and
give him another check now now this kid
was banging the board when he was over
because it was a draw
believe it or not mario has a mate in
four here can we find the mate in four
I'll give you a hint you don't want the
King to be able to move toward the Queen
side okay oh this guy is it already
thinks he's got it okay green to c4
check I give you a hint
you're right okay because he's forcing
the rook to go to d4 cuz obviously if
you go here you're gonna walk in a
checkmate right this is why I like the
other program because it's like mate and
there's no dispute about it right but
this is mate right some dispute but it's
debatable that's the big available but
I'm gonna say that's checkmate okay so
you're forcing the rook to go to where
the king wanted to go to right notice
this little pawn he's doing a great job
he's keeping the King out of d5 so now
if we can just for some over there we're
gonna win so we see the next move gonna
be like yep 22 I like it so I only have
one possible move right
I'd be careful be careful here be
careful there because Knight to e3 does
not work for many reasons I love it love
it love it it looks like I only got one
move and I really don't want to make it
now g6 just a humiliate them
no no cuz they because I hate gets away
so we just take it and love it and we're
the best okay so Mario you missed it but
you know but here's just so excited that
he's checking them all across the board
so so that's not a check but he moves
his King anyway and and so if I was
Mario you have a juicy fork here right
it's true but probably want to just
check them forever until you can no
longer Chuck well hopefully there's
never a point where you can no longer
chuck right you need to keep checking
because in the game actually Mario you
know I don't know where he actually goes
but this is totally winning for I think
I think the kid actually takes with the
Queen I think that's his downfall and
then Mario just keeps winning all the
pawns and then they eventually agreed to
it like sure all okay but he could have
had the win he could have had the win so
so you know you you need to keep
composure so even even or II think the
kid was average crushing Mario in uh
okay even if the guy plays d7 here right
which he did and he takes okay look at
this okay I know I know you just lost
you know your potential Queen and it
hurts it hurts but that doesn't mean
like oh I'm just gonna
making bad moves from here on out you
just got to look on the bright side of
things okay you're up a full rook still
everything will be okay you don't need
to play f3 and you can start playing
better moves okay
you just you can't you can't and he's
playing like hope chest with the rook
and everything and up no excuse for that
okay so so other games from the quad the
quad was very interesting we had the
winner of the Gateway chess League
tournament play playing the same quad
with adjourn and adjourn he smoked all
the scholastic kids he went two and a
half out of three the only kid he drew
was the kid playing white in this
position Mutulu tool Pangea he had white
against the gateway chess League winner
tane so let's see how much to lose the
only one that got to even get a draw out
of the winner adjourned
so let's see how he does against tane
all right so the tool chooses to play
the Scotch which is flying so Bishop
attacks a very interesting line in the
Scotch is if you take here you're like
oh I got double pawns but no what move
can you play to prevent yourself from
getting double pawns
okay he's threatening your queen so you
might want to move it everybody see this
you can play Queen to f6 here and now
you're threatening checkmate and however
he stops the checkmate good luck
stopping that checkmate you just take
all right but he doesn't take he
protects him with Bishop to e3 and now
d6
so Bishop attacks up seven gets us
Bishop out all right now he's going for
checkmate so so there's there's
obviously a bunch of different ways to
stop it with f6 being of obviously the
worst way to stop it but
it's a cool way to stop it anybody see a
cool way to stop it I've actually used
this in a lot of my games 95 yeah
because you're forking the Queen and
Bishop and obviously the most important
part you're protecting f7 so when the
Queen moves you just take the bishop
okay so instead he plays Knight f6 we're
just fine
so Knight takes Knight Bishop takes so
he's got two men attacking the pawn so
he'll protect it with Knight c3
all right so pen excellent so White's
gonna figure something out let's see
what he figures out I know what he does
okay so we already know he does not pin
the knight he attacks the knight all
right so things are about ready to get
crazy so you got to be really good at
calculating before you go into any of
this just I take you take I take you
take I take you take so so if you were
been Feingold you just wouldn't
calculate out any of this and play a
really simple move but but here we go
so Bishop takes pawn alright so yeah I
would take your knight Bishop takes I'll
take your queen I'll take your pawn I
don't want to move my lose my rook right
so I'll I'll move it so it's like okay
I'll take your Bishop it's like okay
I'll take your Bishop so blacks in a lot
of trouble unless you figure something
out quick right I'm sure he calculated
this all out when he did this so if you
if you look at the piece count now black
only has three pieces and white has four
Oh
but maybe Keith can come in and save the
day here yeah all right good good good
you know good good good see it's black
to move he's down a piece he's got to
find a way to recoup a piece cuz if he
can't recoup this piece he might as well
just give it up
all right Kevin's got it
d4 d5 okay yeah and you're not afraid of
this check because uh just because
you're not afraid nobody's afraid of the
check okay yeah there's so much for your
precious chess master so so obviously
he's got two moves here he can just
flat-out take it yeah you never want to
take pin pieces although I would be
taking it just because I want to give
you double isolated pawns so bad like I
can't even tell you how bad I want a
double isolate you look you have every
single one of your pawns will be
isolated right now and you have one more
extra pawn tane you will be doing great
right now I guess you're gonna lose this
poem no but that's neither here nor
there all right so sorry so he keeps the
pin on all right so he loses the pawn
anyway and so now attack the pin piece
right all right so now so now black has
a miracle move here can we see what
don't the Gateway action champion should
have played here a fortune he doesn't
see it because he's too busy playing
haha chess
his move is rook takes Knight right and
then if you take check and then you're
gonna win the rook instead he's like
plays rook the b5 like oh you can't take
it it's ridiculous so
so I guess I guess it's like oh I'm
threatening Bishop takes okay but but
he's gonna see it alright he'll protect
it with the other rook and he gets out
of all the shenanigans
alright so rook attacks the pawn simple
way just push it up
rook big check so now I give them way to
get out of the pen so now when he takes
guess what horrible so obviously just
take with the rook keeping all your
pawns all nice
so as like why I open the B file for my
rook but there's a really easy way right
to protect the b-pawn just push it
simple alright but now he's got his rook
out so King to g8 rook over all right
besides rook to here or here or here or
here all right besides that what is the
worst move black can play on this board
besides just just plan on giving this
rook away and I'll give you a hint King
f8 prepared this horrible move yet rook
e8 horrible ok Kings are the worst
offenders of pieces because when they're
checked they got to save themselves and
it's just humiliating and that's the
gateway action champion for you alright
so so there you go alright so so the
lecture would not be complete unless we
saw the championship game of the small
Swiss
between George and our good friend Zhong
zu he aka Martin he from the Blitz
bounty all right Zang Zoo had the black
pieces Oh so let's watch it from his
perspective I probably won't be showing
it if it was a good game for him either
so I think we know who's gonna win this
one ok so here we go efore yi 6 ok he's
been learning from the great mind for
Akopian all right so let's see how it
plays out here
all right so d3 is George's just gonna
take it easy
watch how how white just just plays
simples little moves and just waits for
his opponent slings ooh just to
completely blow it okay so it might not
be the best idea but if you're playing
players rated under a thousand as long
as you're not the one screwing up you
got something going for you so look
white has done nothing spectacular but
he has not dropped any of his pieces so
obviously if you're playing black you
love this position right because he's
really not threatening any squares in
your position I set for five so maybe
you want to play H six songs ooh yeah
but nope no red well he he's basically
got the night just stuck there because
if he plays Knight up Bishop takes check
all right so George is gonna play some
defense g3 so now if you were playing
black I mean what would you just do
automatically without even thinking yeah
there's some h3 excellent great then he
moves the rook and then you play h6 and
life is great all right but he doesn't
he doesn't he doesn't this develops his
knight fine so d4 all right his first
aggressive move okay he's like oh great
if you're not gonna take these squares
I'm taking them so Knight up attacks the
pawn but doesn't really do much Larry
King g2 Rick the c8 so works below it he
should follow up with c5 if he really
wants to play rook c8 you know just
don't want to put your books on you know
files with pawns behind them you know
for no reason like rook e8 at least
that's a open file right
all right bishop attacks the night all
right now rook to e8 rook e1 b5 all
right he's gonna threaten the night I
guess George doesn't care
all right so he swoops in to g5 here
attacks the bishop so Knight takes the
pawn is that a good move and look look
oh look who's who look who just showed
up here just to see just in the nick of
pain to see his downfall
haeseong's ooh how's it going tonight
does this look familiar kind of like you
know Friday night you want you want to
tell us what your opponent played in
this position and then we got wait to
move you just took the poison to pawn so
does everybody have it Bishop takes pawn
check King over
Queen takes Knight we might yeah we
might have even a more ambitious move
here but hey okay so he takes takes
see what the old lot computer thinks
about this even the default competitor
could figure this one out
nope it loves it loves Keith Smoove
loves it but that's the default Cup it's
alright just take the knight yet free
night everybody's favorite move up six
now we know what to do right h4 h4 is
not gonna get the job done a Queen h4 no
we can just take a free piece huh now
it's just screaming Queen h4 right got a
scream it so Bishop to g6 threatens the
rook Bishop attacks the Queen and now we
have the inevitable check and no reason
to play on from here cuz it's checkmate
and see ya 36 bucks okay glad you got to
relive that alright
that's uh that's the lecture everybody
have a super day